hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trendsenses.com
sorry i wasn't there for the past today
guys i was very very busy at work with
all the market crash and stuff
but i'm back i'm back to do some
technical analysis so today i want to
make an update on
gamestop and amc together in the same
videos
you guys receive it right away and
you're gonna see as usual i have a lot
of interesting and precious information
to share with you
let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys so let's start with amc
first
so the last time i did my video guys i
think it was around the nine level
and i was telling you that i was seeing
a b
wave starting here so let's go back on
the followers time frame
first all right here we go
so just to sum up a bit the situation
i'm here trying to analyze this
whole complex correction and i'm trying
to label it using idiot wave theory
that is just here guys you know i'm just
using this book
all the time and i analyze the market
price action
using this theory and of course i apply
my other indicators and techniques to
this more global theory so here
what i was telling you is that i was
missing an abc to do my w
x y correction and i was trying to give
you
guys some time target and levels
uh before this complex correction gives
us the signal that it is done
and to zoom in here a little bit guys i
was telling you that
here we are waiting for b wave and i
gave you
a technique that he worked perfectly
to actually enter this move up
before it's actually starting
let's see how it played out here you see
guys
very well it played out very well
i just used here the trendline method
that i like to use that is very
efficient that consists of
connecting the highs you have in the
same way don't do this guys
with highs that are not in the same ways
i'm going to show you some examples for
example on gamestop
where it didn't work but here if you
connect
the highs of the same wave you wait for
a breakout you wait for a re-test you
buy the re-test so you would have bought
here guys at nine and then you can
benefit from this whole
move up so this is what happened so let
me just remind you quickly the different
scenarios that we're having
here we are waiting for another
corrective pattern but we we don't know
if it's going to be
zigzag a flat or triangle so
first where the b wave is supposed to go
so if it's a zigzag it's supposed to go
to the 0.618
fee retracement level which is here at
11 all right so this would be a typical
zigzag we go to 11
and then here we probably go to 8 30
right if it's a zigzag
so depending on here where we're having
the reversal i'm sorry guys i'm
you know i think we're gonna have one
more reversal
before going higher again and you know
going to 35 which is my target
so if the b wave goes to 11 the c wave
will probably go to 8 30 but if the b
wave guys goes to you know around
the 12 area so we know it is a flat and
a flat usually
has a c wave that goes to the bottom of
wave a once again you can have some
flats
that go slightly deeper let me show you
this
you just use this file that is you know
my guide to apply the idea to a theory
so you want to check the flat just check
the flat
all right so here is a flat so you know
the usual flat is like this
a b c with b wave going to the top of
wave a and c wave going to the bottom of
wave a as well but you can also have
flats like this where the c wave goes
slightly below so what i'm just saying
is that it's not because the b
wave retraced almost fully wave a
that the c wave won't go a bit below
wave a as well but it still gives you
more likelihood for this scenario
to be true i mean the c wave going to
the bottom of wave a
all right and our last scenario is that
we're gonna have a triangle and if it's
a triangle it's gonna have
a shape like this it's gonna be
something like this so we're gonna see
where we're going and then the y wave
would only go to here so this scenario
is still at play
everything looks exactly like it should
so i'm very confident that this complex
correction
is actually gonna be done once we
complete
this third corrective pattern once again
here guys i'm trying to find
a triple three so just type
double three and you're gonna see the
triple threes as well you go to the
fourth position and here you're gonna
see what i'm looking for i'm looking for
a wxy correction so it can be a flat any
three
for example the zigzag and and a
triangle or it can be a flat
a zigzag and a zigzag all right so we're
looking for something like this
that is usually a sideways correction of
an association of three corrective
pattern
moving sideways and here this is exactly
what we're having the w
this one guys this is what i'm trying to
do w x
y so i'm wondering where the y would be
here
here here or here so let's see i think
we have until end of may
to find out where this could go and then
of course we're gonna use the same
techniques
as we always do guys to enter the train
so you don't enter the train just
because the level looks attractive this
is not
how traders are actually working i mean
this is not how i like to work
you enter the trade once you have the
signal so once again i repeat
the kind of signal that you're gonna
have you can use it as well for the end
of wave b guys
you see here you connect the lows
and whenever this breaks guys it's
probably going to be the beginning of
the c wave all right the same way we did
it here whenever this trend line breaks
here
it breaks it retests it goes higher here
it's gonna break
re-test and go lower and here then we're
gonna do
you know what we are looking for and go
higher but first
we must finish this complex correction
that cannot be finished
unless we have these three corrective
patterns together
so that's it for amc let's go to see
what we have
on gamestop so gamestop is here
the situation looks a bit more
complicated
let me remind you guys what i was
telling you let me put this
in green in a blue sorry up
so i was very convinced that this was
what was at play and i was expecting you
know a triangle here a
abcde and here i was supposed to have my
z-wave but guys things have changed you
know
when i give you like a view like this
it's only my preferred scenario but of
course
you always need to be aware that there
are many other scenarios that can take
place
you know even in the same global view
which is bullish for me
here we don't have this triangle anymore
so let me show you guys what happened on
the hourly time frame
and this is why you know even if your
scenario is not the correct one
trading is about not losing money here
by knowing
whenever it's not the scenario that is
going to happen
and here you see when i connect the laws
that are here
one two three four five
six and the sevens guys let's zoom in
even more
and let's see what happens here guys
let's see what happened
let's see how this triangle this foaming
triangle actually
broke so we are like this
so let me connect better on the five
minutes time frame
it's just a question of cutoff when i
change the time frame i
sometimes need to reconnect but i want
to show you guys that this connections
are here very good
so it's connected here here here here
and
it gives you the breakdown signal so
here guys on the 10th of may at 157 when
it got
broken guys this was for me the signal
that the triangle pattern
won't happen it cannot break all right
it should have
hold it didn't hold then it means it's
not a triangle and it's another pattern
so here the way i would have traded it
if
i was involved in trading game stuff i
would have just stopped my position
around you know i usually like to take
one or two percent buffer so probably
around this level all right
i would have stopped my position maybe
around 100
and you know 53 something like this and
then i would have waited for
some better signals to go back into the
trade and
sometimes i would have bought you know
lower than where i sold
sometimes slightly higher it doesn't
matter guys you know what matters is not
to keep a position that you're not
comfortable with
here i wouldn't be comfortable to hold
gamestop shares on the short term
on the very short term i mean so let me
show you guys now the different
scenarios that we're having
so once again guys it's always the same
thing you know this is the beauty of
technical analysis is that
once you've seen it you know many times
you know that it's always the same
things that gonna happen so let me here
replace up my triangle so if it's not a
triangle so let me get rid of it
what can it be guys you must know it by
now if you're watching my videos it's
either flat
a zigzag or triangle you know you'll
only have three corrective patterns
then they can be combined together and
give you some complex corrections like
we're having here
but in every trench of this complex
correction we're gonna find one of the
patterns we know
so here the triangle is of the table so
we having a zigzag
or a flat left now let's see if it's
zigzag or flat we already have the b
wave here
which is actually very useful so let's
use this information because we know
that if the b
wave is going towards the is retracing
almost hundred percent of wave a then
it's not a zigzag it's a flat
so it's going to give us information on
where the c wave gonna go
so let's measure it let's measure it
properly
and we go to the 0.786 percent
so unfortunately it's in between guys a
flat is usually 85
90 then it would be a flat so if the b
wave would have gone here
then it would be a flat and a zigzag
usually goes to
0.618 so it's between the two of them
but it looks to me
more like a flat so the flat scenario
means wave c goes
to the bottom of wave a area and where
is the bottom of wave a guys
it's at 132 exactly so let me put it
here
so i assume that we might go to the 132
level
and then finally bounce back
and of course one more scenario is that
we don't stop at 132 and as you saw guys
for the flat
correction so the flat correction can
look like this abc with c wave going to
the bottom of wave a
but it can also look like this all right
with the c wave going
slightly below the bottom of wave a this
is still a flat correction so
again stop even going to you know the
worst case scenario would be 110
if we are doing a zigzag would still be
possible
or 132 so we would need to analyze very
carefully what is happening here
and what you guys can do what you're
looking for is
as usual always the same thing you
connect
the highs that you have in the wave and
you're looking for a breakout
so here the breakout would be given to
us
for example around 152 area if we trade
above that
then the c wave is done and you know
that for like 90
chance this could have worked everywhere
in the move up guys you can
do this technique uh almost everywhere
you know you can do it for
for example here you see
you can capture this move up basically
you can do this technique as long as you
stay in the same way
what you cannot do what i want you to
tell you guys at the beginning of the
video is for example to connect
this height that is in the wave a with
for example this height that is in wave
b
you know and this gives you kind of a
trend line but that's
you guys cannot use because that's why
idiot wave counting is important before
you're using trend lines
is because they are not belonging to the
same wave
so they're not gonna give you some clear
signals
so you cannot make a trend line here and
try to play the breakout
this is not the kind of things that i do
but maybe some traders do it i don't
know
so to sum up the situation guys we are
actually waiting
for the sea wave to bottom i think it
can bottom
to be honest everywhere so we are
looking for the breakout of the sea wave
this is the best way to know it's
finished
and the lowest level it could go i would
say 110 all right
even if it goes there i'm still bullish
i'm still bullish
and i'm still in this kind of sideways
correction that i'm trying to fit with
idiot with patterns
and i would still have my you know
longer term scenario that is holding
let me remind you my longer term
scenario is that this is just a one
this is a two and we are having a three
that is coming all right probably going
to go to the 500
area correct and then blow it up and go
to the 100
800 maybe 1000 area this is what would
make the most sense for me
so guys that's it for me i hope you
enjoyed this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button
so you're gonna be the first to know
when i upload anything new
and stay close to show see you guys